la jeunesse de
des opérations c'est quoi c'est que
l'année dernière une autre association
guyanaise était venu en martinique est
précisément au cs l'association les
carolines était venu présenter le tout
nouveau et avec notamment un défilé de
troubles ou une animation explications
autour de ça le contact a été très bien
passé bien sûr été très fructueux il
descendit que étant et la demande qui
avait deux des changes de cultures
guyanaises les changes là l'idée a mûri
dans la tête des membres de
l'association vous n'avez pourquoi pas
de voir venir et continuer cet échange
pour cette recommandation tout ce que
nous allons pouvoir proposer complet
sera préparée sur place
nous sommes revenus à quelques
condiments qu'on ne pouvait pas trouver
sur le sur la martinique mais tout sera
fait sur place donc malheureusement le
goût d'avoir des regrets mais n'ont pas
plus de le faire venir en aide
l'occasion de revenir une autre fois il
ya aussi la qui parle des réclames et
latifa au lait de coco mais ça aussi de
faire une sélection de vos du menu donc
par exemple on a proposé hier parce que
nous sommes arrivés la semaine
gastronomique commence à coincer mardi
pour aller jusqu'à vendredi pour
clôturer en feu d'artifice dimanche
nos clients nous allons proposer une
palette de couacs accents poulet boucané
vous a proposé aussi
une daube de confort a été très apprécié
la clôture de cette manifestation ce
sera dimanche par un déjeuner dansant
qui se tiendra de 12h à 18h au cis de la
martinique autour duquel yoann est
forcément la gastronomie parce que nous
sommes une association culinaire
nous avons associé à ce projet
l'association des pompes à dos qui est
notre référent local en terme de
préservation de la culture vestimentaire
et traditionnelles des romains des robes
de de nos fables rihanna 10 c'est à dire
que madame c est aussi un chercheur de
madame c'est ceux-là sont les compagnons
viendra nous faire un défilé du plus
d'une quinzaine de robes avec une avec
une explication sderot pourquoi ces roxy
enfin et pas d'autres et à quelle
occasion est importé parce que leur
passait bien mec tout est lié au repas
je dire que c'est un set un troyen
c'est officiel mais c'est un élément
parmi 1 et parmi d'autres